it's great to welcome to the program
today vincent racanello who is a
virology professor at columbia
university and also host of the podcast
this week in virology um it's so great
to have you on today i appreciate it
my pleasure glad i could make it after
all that rain yesterday yeah i saw the
videos it's some something else um
listen i'll just jump into some things
because there are maybe some specific
things that that are new ground for my
audience that i think might be
interesting to talk about and i think
it'll it'll open up a broader discussion
with something like the idea that
there's a period of time during which
you can be incubating this virus in
other words you you have been infected
you don't yet have symptoms you would
not yet test positive if you were to be
tested
what is actually happening during that
period of time is it that there are some
virus particles in you but they've not
established themselves in your system
like what is taking place at that point
so let's think when you get infected
you're typically inhaling
droplets that have been produced by
someone else right they're infected
their droplets have virus you inhale
them into your nose typically they go
into the cells lining
your nose and further back which we call
the nasopharynx and the viruses then
attach
to cells
it's not easy to do that that's why a
lot of viruses have to get in you to
start an infection but the virus is
attached to cells they're taken into the
cells and then they begin to multiply
and in the very first hours
it's very low levels the viruses are in
maybe a few cells
they're beginning to multiply you can't
really detect it by pcr but then you go
above a threshold where those cells
produce virus the virus infects
neighboring cells and it goes on and on
maybe it takes about 20 hours for a
cycle to complete in a cell so after a
few days you are now at the point where
you would test positive by pcr so in
that interval that you're interested in
the virus is multiplying your your
immune system is beginning to detect it
you have the earliest immune system
which is called innate immunity can
detect what's going on there and in fact
most infections are stopped very early
on before they progress any farther
but then
if the innate immune system doesn't work
and part of that is interferons which
you may have heard about which block
virus infections in many ways if the
innate immune system doesn't work the
virus keeps multiplying and then we have
activation of other immune systems which
include antibodies and t cells and then
it becomes a race to see if the virus
can outpace it and then after a certain
number of days
maybe five days on average you might
then feel symptoms you might get a
scratchy throat you might get a headache
you might get a fever and so forth which
might prompt you to go get tested and
bingo there you go you you get a pcr
test and you're positive i have um
friends who have gotten a bunch of the
abbott
home tests and for example a friend had
a birthday party with 10 people last
week and of course everyone had to be
vaccinated but he also tested everybody
on the way in and his belief was
if there was a negative from someone who
was in this state you and i just
described the virus has entered their
body but they they are not yet testing
positive that it's okay because they are
almost certainly not contagious at that
point is is that actually our best
assessment of one's uh level of con of
how contagious you are during that
intervening period
yes the pcr tests are very sensitive
so if if they are picking up nucleic
acid you have a good amount of viral
multiplication and if you're negative on
this test and you go to an affair for a
couple of hours certainly in the time of
that you're not going to change from
non-infectious to being infectious so if
you're negative
i would say you have 24-hour window
before you might even start shedding
virus and infecting others
when it comes to uh the conversation of
variants
i've read a number of pieces that say
that evolutionarily the way that there
is selection pressure on these variants
the idea of a significantly more deadly
variant becoming dominant is not
particularly likely i know that there's
a lot in there about level of
infectivity versus
the the the deadly nature and and a lot
of things to unpack but let's start with
is it true that it is unlikely that a
much more deadly strain would become
dominant if so why if not why not
when we look at all the viral outbreaks
in humans over the years for the most
part
viruses do not become more deadly if
anything over a long period they become
less deadly they become better adapted
to their hosts and i'm talking many many
years maybe hundreds of years in time
and so
there's no there's no
evolutionary reason why a virus would
become more deadly
because it would kill its host faster
and it would be less likely to transmit
and transmission transmission of course
is the raison d'etre for a virus so
the variants are certainly arising
because of some kind of selection
pressure right we think part of it is
immunity in the population we didn't see
these variants until
late in 2020 when a lot of people
globally had already been infected or
vaccinated and had some kind of immunity
so antibodies can certainly put pressure
on a virus
so that you would select the virus that
is slightly different and can evade the
antibody it happens with influenza virus
every year and they're probably other
selection mechanisms that we don't know
about because these variants have a lot
of different changes so i think in the
end what we can say about the variants
they're selected probably mainly because
of immune pressure they're not likely to
be more deadly even though there's some
studies here and there that suggest that
they're not very well done they're not
very well controlled i think the main
issue is
is immunity and escape from it and over
a period of time would we or let me put
it a different way there is already a
trial going on
with a modified mrna vaccine tailored to
more recent variants i don't know the
exact timeline of when that may become
the one that you get when you go to cvs
or walgreens or wherever the case may be
is it likely that like the flu shot we
would need to be tailoring the vaccine
to the most recent variants
it's certainly possible now with
influenza that can happen every year or
two right we tailor a new vaccine
and we have so much experience with
influenza that we know
when antibody levels drop below a
certain point in people we know that
correlates with them getting more severe
disease we don't have that infra
information yet for source cov2 we don't
know what antibody levels are protective
we don't know how low you can go and
still be protected from disease right
now
the vaccines protect against severe
disease and death even though antibody
levels are declining so it's not clear
if when we would need to change the
vaccine i think we have to wait and see
if more and more vaccinated people this
is the key
do fully vaccinated people start to get
more sick do they get severe disease do
they die when we reach that point then
we talk about
changing the virus vaccine earlier on um
there was the
idea that was much repeated i i guess we
would call it a belief
that the two-dose regimen of either the
pfizer or moderna vaccine
would likely be good for at least a year
there were discussions of two to three
years etc more recently there's been the
the data from israel that shows that the
antibody levels although as you say we
don't know exactly what that means in
the real world but antibody levels seem
to start declining after eight months
there's the idea maybe after six months
one would get a third dose i've also
read some
uh doctors say the third dose will
almost certainly be the last one at this
point it seems to me we really just
don't know we really just can't say
three is going to be it what is it that
we need to be looking at to really get
an answer to that question
so one thing we have to understand is
that with every human viral vaccine you
get vaccinated six to eight months later
your antibody levels decline it's the
natural process there's nothing new
about sarco v2 vaccines and antibodies
declining i mean although people are
making it out to be a big deal okay they
are declining and
with that there has been a push for
boosters what's not declining though is
protection against
severe disease and death that remains
robust so the antibodies level decline
you may get infected
even if you're fully vaccinated but that
happens with just about every other
human viral vaccine that we know about
but you don't get serious disease that's
how we tested these vaccines to prevent
covet of any kind now we're getting mild
covet even after fully vaccinated and so
the key for a booster so i think the
booster idea is somewhat flawed because
the idea is to push antibody levels up
again but they're going to decline in
six to eight months so are we going to
go every year and give people a booster
i don't think that's a good public
health strategy frankly
the key is do we still prevent severe
disease and death so far we are doing
that and as long as that protection
remains strong then i don't think we
need to have a booster and to think that
it would be the last one well there's
simply no data to suggest that i think
that would be great if it were but we
simply don't know when it comes to the
seasonality of this
when we were going into last fall
there was generally speaking a consensus
that we were going to see a big increase
and the
the explanations vary depending on what
what you looked at part of it was
similar explanation with influenza that
as it gets colder people spend more time
inside and that that's going
going to increase transmission we were
not yet vaccinating at that time uh this
fall we seem to be seeing at least the
growth of cases slow down it's not yet
declining but if we're six to eight
weeks after where europe is maybe we are
starting to get to a peak so maybe we
won't see that increase into fall and
winter although maybe we will what's our
best assessment right now as to the see
the quote seasonality of this and what
is actually the source of that what what
generates that
so we really don't know
how seasonal covid is right because it's
brand new and when you have a pandemic
that trumps all seasonality effects so
for example in in 2009 the pandemic
influenza virus emerged in august which
is totally weird because they usually
come out in in the winter but when
there's a pandemic most people are not
immune so the virus can spread even
though it's the wrong season so that's
what we're seeing uh with source cov2
now there are other coronaviruses that
infect us they cause common colds there
are four different ones they are
seasonal and it's likely just by
extension that stars cov2 will be
seasonal as well although still we're in
this pandemic phase where seasonality
gets trumped by simply if you have a lot
of susceptible people around which we
still do
the virus will reproduce whenever it
wants to
what is the actual mechanism for the
seasonality is it as simple as the
temperature forces people indoors and
increases spread
well that's a good question because it
you know seasonality is different for
different viruses in the heyday of polio
in the in the world
that was one that spread in the summer
right warm weather when kids were out
playing and so forth but influenza is in
the winter in seasonal and temperate
climates and we think that's because the
low temperature allows the virus to
remain infectious longer and the low
humidity keeps those droplets that you
exhale keep that keeps them very small
because in humid conditions they take on
water they drop to the ground more
quickly when it's dry they can travel
farther and infect people but we we
don't know much about that for most
other viruses it's a really tough topic
to understand
so i know how to frame my next question
have you seen the mask efficacy study
from bangladeshi data
i have not you haven't okay tell me
so i'll my understanding of the
bangladeshi study on on mask efficacy is
that
for older cohorts there was definitively
reduced transmission from mask wearing
although the statistical significance of
the reduction seemed to be lower the
younger the cohort you looked at there
may be other confounding factors there
so you know i think that the devil is
probably in the details what's our best
assessment right now
of the impact of masks on reducing
spread because it's become very
politicized and controversial and maybe
the science doesn't suggest it should be
yeah so masking is tough because it's
hard to do a good study right you would
love to be able to take a group of
people with masks and without and
challenge them with virus and see the
mask but we just can't do that um so we
have to use surrogates and so i think
the best estimate for for covid is that
when worn properly and that's a big if
because not everyone wears them properly
and i see more and more people just
having them below their nose because
they're they're so used to it maybe it
stops 60
of transmission and it makes sense
because the droplets that carry the
virus they get caught up in the mask
material it's not the virus that gets
trapped it's the droplets carrying the
virus so if you wear them properly so
there are no gaps maybe sixty percent
it's not going to be a hundred percent
ever and we know that in many countries
where they use masks
quite often in respiratory virus season
it does make an impact so my view is
that it's an easy thing to do it's not
too much of an inconvenience i'm used to
it by now so i don't really see the
issue
when it comes to treatments i i don't
i'm glad to have you weigh in on
particular treatments if you feel so
inclined and as though you can do so but
more generally speaking
what is the reason why some of these
widely available cheap drugs
enter the news cycle as possibly
efficacious treatments is it simply that
there's stuff lying around that's cheap
and doctors decide to to throw it at the
virus and see what happens
yeah i think that's part of it there are
i mean the the
the tendency is to take a drug that's
already approved say by the fda
unlicensed and you can use it off label
in people without too much trouble so
for a few drugs early on in the pandemic
some labs did experiments showing that
the drugs could inhibit virus
multiplication in cells and that was
immediately translated to usage in
people without a good clinical trial and
so none of those repurposing
have really resulted in anything
worthwhile
it's unfortunate because you would love
to have a pill that you could take at
the moment of your positive that would
help you a lot we still don't have that
and if you want to know why
besides these repurposings failing it's
because the billions of dollars were put
into vaccines rather than drugs and
that's that's the bottom line if we put
20 billion dollars into drugs we'd have
some right now is that right you're
confident that this is not an unsolvable
problem it's just not been we haven't
done put enough into it
absolutely and in fact i think we could
have had a drug before the pandemic even
started we could have had one ready and
it would have stopped the pandemic and
that's a failing of research and big
pharma for sure what type would it be an
antiviral or what type of drug would it
be it would be an antiviral because we
knew after sars1 that there were virus
similar viruses and bats that could
infect human cells and all we needed to
do was pick a target which is highly
conserved among those different stars
like coronaviruses and bats and develop
an inhibitor easy could be done within a
few years not very great costs it could
even be tested in a phase one and be
ready for subsequent studies once the
pandemic began
when it comes to the um hypotheses about
the origins of this uh pandemic and this
virus
there was a period very early on where
so-called lab leak hypotheses made a
splash
it sort of went away
a few months ago it was back
joe biden was asked about it jen saki
was asked about it basically everybody
said we should investigate everything
but until we have evidence to believe
something we shouldn't say that that's
what's most likely it's now disappeared
again essentially from from the public
discourse to me it seemed very sort of
media driven there was a decision made
implicitly that now we're going to ask
about this and then then it sort of went
away
where is your mind on
how this should be investigated and
whether there's any there there
it's always been clear to me that this
virus just like sars won before it and
all the other coronas and in fact all
the human viruses it came from a wild
animal somewhere
not from a lab no no virus that has
spread this way has ever come from a lab
which is not to say it couldn't happen
again but that lab in wuhan was not
working on these viruses there's plenty
of evidence that they're closely related
viruses in nature and i do think that
the lab leak idea is just a distraction
politically motivated
it's an easy answer for a tough problem
it took 10 years to find
the virus which came into people for
sars1 and so it might take as long to
find where that virus is the precursor
we don't have anything close to it yet
it requires a lot of wildlife sampling
and if we're going to have
international arguments with countries
that's not going to happen but a paper
just came out last week showing that if
you look at rodents in china you can
find these coronaviruses so we've barely
sampled wild animals and that's where
the answer is going to be for sure
last thing i want to talk about um there
was the likely
imprudent idea of easter 2020 as when
things would go back to normal from the
former president that was not
particularly realistic there were high
hopes for this summer
um
dr fauci has recently talked about
spring of 2022 if there's enough
vaccination
do we really know when the the serious
decline of the pandemic is is going to
be at this point and does it simply
depend on variance and vaccination
well i i was telling people in the
spring that by this fall
2021 it would be controlled in countries
that vaccinate 80 percent of the
population right and unfortunately we
haven't reached that in the u.s so we're
we're not controlling it and i think if
we get to that level of vaccination you
will control serious disease
it doesn't look like we're going to get
there in the u.s we might have to get
there by by some natural infection which
is going to take longer because you
every cycle of outbreaks doesn't get
everyone infected and you have to depend
on another one if we could vaccinate 80
of the population by the spring of 2022
then yes the u.s could control it but of
course many other countries will not be
able to get there so we're talking about
a few more years globally until we get
most of the human population vaccinated
i'm trying to do the math in the u.s if
we're at 52 and we want to get to 80
that's 28 additional percentage points
where at the beginning of september so
you're talking about if we say spring is
the end of march it's seven months to do
28
it's only four percent a month which
seems so doable and yet we see it move
by a tenth of a percent a week and then
you you it's it's not looking
particularly good
yeah there are a couple of problems of
course one is that under 12 you can't be
vaccinated yet we're hoping that that
that changes by the end of the year that
would make a big difference because you
know if you had 80 percent of the
population immunized you you would still
have classrooms with 30 kids with no
vaccines that that's a problem yeah
you know no one's going to be protected
and then of course there are people who
simply don't want to be vaccinated for
various reasons and it's unfortunate and
you know i try and reason with them
calmly i'd love to talk to them one on
one but some of them are just dead set
against it so that's the obstacle yeah
that's uh that's for sure uh make sure
to check out the podcast this week in
virology we've been speaking with
vincent racanello who is not only one of
the hosts but also a virology professor
at columbia university
so great having you on today
my pleasure great conversation i
appreciate it